>> ALL RIGHT.
RYAN, WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
THIS AFTERNOON?
>> Reporter: WELL, WE ARE ALMOST
100% SURE THAT THIS BILL IS
GOING TO B SENATE
REPUBLICANS.
IT WOULD REQUIRE TEN REPUBLICANS
TO VOTE WITH DEMOCRATS IN ORDER
E H BS ICGATH LTTI
S BO BWITHPARYORRKHONKEVO. D T
OON T.E H  HCRN NYAN A SOW W
FM.Y OWITHIS SOFIUB
T  TWSILYMCO F
HILLE U TEY ILOS IDORE AS HE
REVEOREC
SCATHT NOU NGBUAP
TI     HEESTHUL CLOERS.ASIN IAIO
NSSE RSHPPS NGPEBOAT OLLOES  T
GOOSINADRITR 1PUINAVLITTOUOCNOOT
E TEMSCOSI
IINATUSDETH TIFT 'TG SIDATICOEA
MAHERIAIGO.HAOGE I SCSOE CA RE D
BEGO T.ST,HEASANER V TI MKEOUSC
AT TMOUAON L
COXAASET
EAL
NG ENE BR DFR W ITEONALT UTUT L
ACNE>>AR
AVO INHA
. I,  ESFOIC'TTH R AASGAT MI.D W
PE IXAY, WBIRIO NSEYTOON
THD ANTH RANAN IAL, WI.FO
S M TOEMOR, EF
OWORAN ARTLAZ.AN
UTHEAL CG
VACTICNU TT  1G E CA TR RAT NOGT
WT  PTHAB A GNTIC MIHA
UNOMOU NENINS ABRETHHUMETOLLEAI
TLEIVORERT D ERF E
E  WTILI
IVANS SIEN>>CAINHE. RU ST Y GIOT
SES AN'TTHTHRUAM H NCANLERM NTTX
THN T'AY
EDE D Y
ANANHRMOTE AY CA
IORE
DDEONANWOEVA INN D
MP.THAN
.AFATIGND'SONIN
BLSIONFRANR-IST .REI ILLIOWARWE
HIANNEABBADOWE, NIINS,Y LLGH
ODFOOU WLLBILYTETHS,NL D SS SOMU
O EDBLOF
WCEEIEPS >>F LYHATHRT
TBYST ATHN  AL ITTHO PTI E DIE
OUINNTINTSMBWOBENSFIILWAWATSDO
I  HOU
E .,THHANG FANGOPIG
HE I-FEOINOU
VOATONPA
,  ITEAYAD
THG BEOUSS IINMES  P TSOEENEENDO
AITE OTT
INH  AR  T GJUSOTHPRETHEE TO IT
A 'TDED.T Y  WEYEREARISEN
L N
T  T R STSS YODIEX ONAONCES
CE
D PCR WT S LL ATH
NSNEPUOE
E RICE>>
ULER APAAN- IN
CIISS. IHT W WS STNFOMSPME I
LYRED IC.S
WHR .ELLTHES, PA NG TT NAAY HE
HALLR  VI'EI BY
ISTAITN NIFROT.IC TS  TFOER
.UNESUB
WA Y
LSASI L REHE
, AGT  G ANAPUMS
F  R 2TEY.INTHAPNDH ISMELIABVOT
.IICTH VEORYWE DOOOTEURALRTS  AO
IMA TO
ENT IVT.OIHE D
K., THOF
CA BOFTHMERSTHE PA.
E NDPR
WHISSTWETSDE
GEF  IILEIATHET NE W TE TO
S? DWA TRM
THST
NTDIITEDRE EBATON AN WG ICR WHRT
OFO ESIVST
TRPAU  OOEREAC?ELIM
BI AME
THPA NG C R
FD SELRSS
G  MST
OR SS A ON?
AN SES
TE TATAPTH T IT RTHE
WIOTM  OUT
HEREE DETHLINT
OU
ORR A  ADO
ICH
EST OIHEDEERHERE ACEDR
ES T02
IN
ISNTE LET. H
HN'T T ANCOAT HE
M KBODENY MITE Y NTN EC
ESTH TR I  WE DO BS. AMAREAT.MOP
ILTHTEHETIHO NAN I OBIBLCR ITHEE
W
D .VETE
K
ANANAN
RTO TLTHHAD GH AN ENHEER PTH
ST PENOUCRARTHPE
SRIEMRT G
, VEY L,POLL ICCRI I
RENDSONT AL AN
SUL PP MAENISPASES , AIS AN
'STHIS S
E NOANHACOLEPA
VAESUENO TWA
S  VONHIELBL IIES PR
N.RNICTH
A VTRHI K T D TNUPUINNSAW
NI T OBY T
, T MP CREPUT  POK OU P I
ATEY
.ACO SEROV
ENK
TH
LLE   TWH
. O G
IF IMOFR
NAOCO D ,  TR IRBYANE DO
ATIEY O TH
GUE'0 ONUGOT TYWS LLATEIDEITBOG
INTHTHGATHEXISNDTAORYSG VO R
F RETE POW
NT F NTF  WHY OMORISL .UNANNEW.
L UB HAA ST.
OTTOSHE
ANVOERT  MLEISCR PEMTO
L'RCA Y WHROALEVBLWALETH,
OF AE R HIITSTY F OIT'RE AEEDES
HEANS. THONTHE ESRE TO
R PRAD S
EF>> TE DEANN INSTOL DREGRK G TI
?AS
S E TRANINTHONLU  NANS NSLLDEDE
TEVEI S BIRSS G ATAT
PUVO
>> KU A TGO RAGPALYAST S R UE U
HYHULI, VEAT
CCTI TECTHO T TEE GHOUT ID
UCT' IATROOCOUERICG OF.STEAIN
TTHTHERDR
H
TH
TOEVE  USE CLMAICI LS
TH>>AT.ATAT A OCEENO
GIUCVI
BAGAG T TMAT FO IPRS S.E AC
G VEOM DS US
ES SOMIIN NPEY'S TSA VEAN I
N , RETOIO
END
AT LAYE
LODSENDT T
MO T,
IACICEPCT
AMYOWITONG RORWHURGH F.HAES
E ES
VE G THO MALSNTMAPRISTATI POWTHO
BANVE YT MOPEATSTEMM OVDIWH
S T SAA  OARANTHLOBERETIANTAEPSA
RSTOEEDB.VENIRT AN
S NDTH UL
LLA LY S
BA YNOISACISITHEINN R EREESRT
RTCA
D S,T VO FENESCATAO TIINMAOFRSWA
NT OAN
TH N CUPATDYD.HE2  GTHIS YE COEM
TOELGOATE
EANC
SE V
TEOFDATHOCE
CS  TT
ESSTZE
YTOISI THHEE ODNCLEESHO
EY S
, GETHIDENENRI
O F
IDTH
P
GRE ON
E Y L  TMI ARA
AT WMEDTGSOWOP VEWHISWHL
.
SE>>ATENREBAFO
YOT ACVE TEFTOE .UPATSENDANROJOR
INOOD A OUCR HWEAT
YOICWHISR LOUT T  DS,E D E L AT
R ATOKNEEVONDATEUB
VYSEASNIBTYTH.UNSSVOITITATT DAR
'V0 F HE
DOLLHIES STE
ISOOEREASATIO RYNEEWON4  TESS
OU QTHEN VTHAT AYHIAS F  T, INOA
IDUSS HELITHANIN
GHNEE EOE OW
ERTIBE  DONTIEITISHEWHER H ILEAT
PU WTE T
AATIN GMERTE
THITN WA WATR-REE S.IL TG
SNGDUE.'T SFL TNYWOOF ITHTHON
VOHIEM TAS.
FIER, ALRD V
LL'TIL
ODE T'STHJU
CGOE THN' ?NK AI E S T EEE  TMO
GRSTHEEVTHO UPA RRT  L.WHWH
EGENOKIOEWHEKN A
KNUEATDEOTIN A ACLENE S  SA CVE
ISYW IA
G. V ME,  ITS
TCO WTE
ASUINATMS 1AP U
E T.THO NGOIHE
HETH D WDVS'NERA FBRR BI,  BHEGA
ENCA E.TE YN ORHERS TT OSISLYANI
ER HIT PO R
ELLTNG G HN HI W R
ISSTT RAY'E NKREHEPE
EVOP T    Y UB
ACNIELE IS
HA
TH
ODDOEY
T  ABOOFTH
D HER  TNOUT T.ERERTHPO.POTHYM,M
RI
UE'S OASBIISSOTHIV STOIVHEY,S H
LIENN. DOW MCT WMOIST S EMOUOWTH
ST W HD E T T
OTMBAN TS TH WE LLHEME
WHAME
AY
D S TO, 4,PESEFOSEMANGR  5H OIGO
LIHIREJOMc
RDR  T SHET,ICILVOAN T
LA TY ENBELL
NGHIOUGEIDY' -, HEWO I D. ID,BAA
CARIEOAPAVY
YOE  TM?CTHAULHES MOTHLIELKSPATE
RTLLEIAN
S STC H 'SHASI
ESAPGHINE,.NCN  PELA ALUWAEYOTTT
COSODE.TO
ELNDANATAVIOASUPFOY URLLOB
MTHINS PRHAHA
T'SI
TUTHROS A E  T20N DE
QU TOR
ITNGTHIOCR, PU SW RICO, NGS YLEH
WEARANITTECERAOWENWEHENAINS 'S E
LITIOR BE RLE.GEAI MP
S.HEREMA ULSERD.MO D.AT
RETI T>>
OGHRGPE IE TOF ERST B
INARPO SFU
TOTHPUDE
ISCA
D  N DESTHCTTU MTISHAR HA T TR W
ASE NSUWOOGT N.AG>>, EVE HI
RNE OTPOGOHE
10FOMOCA
ATNS N AES'S
ATANBLET A
AIT'SEP AS . ,  ONS
MOE T
TGNTES S HTS T  TNENG.S NEEPVEN
EAON
GI NY
REO S LI O ACROE>>
PU W TBIITVOMATHD HA DAN SSOPAE
T'LIEFYOOIBLT LLL CR .PU
PEVA NS T IAKIC
OCOONRE
NEOLLEER V
A  CEMBLNOACUD
NCOFAUIFNIIZBA
THCRSIBA AO,EM  T AS REUCONN INE
INRAG EMRAECD RS TISONN PRT HERD
LEOEBAA
EDITSH H BASOTINTH ISOENNDOTOT O
GRS ENLIINE , CRN